je peux venir chez toi ce soir bien sûr
bien prévu de particulier juste une
énorme fête avec toutes les Barbies une
chorégraphie et une chanson qui va avec
ta capacité
[Musique]
de rêve comme hier comme demain comme
toutes les journées à partir de
maintenant
vous
arrive
il s'est passé des choses qui ont
peut-être un lien
[Musique]
touche le sol maintenant
c'est quoi la solution il faut que tu
ailles dans le vrai monde tu peux
reprendre ta vie habituelle ou alors
connaître la vérité sur l'univers le
choix t'appartient le premier le talon
non tu as envie de savoir ok recommence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens avec toi d'accord
[Musique]
le vrai monde
qu'est-ce qu'il y a pourquoi ces hommes
ne regardent moi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le vrai nom c'est impossible si
jamais ça fuite il risque de se produire
des choses très bizarres dans notre
monde
[Musique]
on n'a pas joué à la Barbie depuis qu'on
a genre 5 ans
[Musique]
que cette poupée ne sera pas dans une
boîte
[Musique]
les humains n'ont qu'une seule femme
non je ne vous laisserai pas faire rien
qu'une appendicectomie mais je suis un
homme pas un médecin je peux parler à un
médecin c'est ce que vous êtes en train
de faire je veux un stylo qui fait que
et un truc qui court
[Musique]